normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government Media
Matters is threatened by rumble's
mission to protect a free and open
internet so the reaction is to deceive
the public and scare advertisers for
example on March 14th Media Matters
claimed that advertisements of for
Netflix which were appearing on Rumble
had been placed on videos that violated
our content policies however according
to Google analytics the week before
publication of that Media Matters
article there had been zero page views
of that video this means that the Media
Matters activist who took the
screenshots was the first human being to
actually view the Netflix ad on the
video in question though their story
left the false impression that it was a
widespread problem the same is true for
most of the videos set by Media Matters
all of which were removed from Rumble as
soon as we were made aware of them it's
clear that Media Matters intends to
mislead and deceive about advertisements
on Rumble in order to hamper free speech
and harm law iding employers who only
want to advertise their product and
services yo it's torous interference you
there's no reason why you you can't just
say you know Chris and they're trying to
cost you money and damage your business
take it to the the the monetary uh issue
right here prove damages let Media
Matters outright admit that they're
doing this and then show it to a judge
do we know who funds them uh it's it
well probably George Soros yeah that
would be no I think that's actually
easily confirmed that was a big article
that people were sharing but it's it's a
nonprofit that receives a bunch of
donations he says Media Matters doesn't
do anything for free so who is funding
this outrageous targeting activity who
is paying for them free speech and and
why are they afraid ofe free expression
online speaker Johnson rep Jordan it's
time for Congress to ask hard questions
Elon Musk respond saying they have a
long track record of evil Deeds an
investigation is badly needed I will
tell you this right now I will place a
large sum of money I mean this
figuratively a gentleman's bet let's say
that sure that the US government is
working directly with Media Matters in
some way yeah yeah us us what's probably
happening is government actors and Media
Matters employees probably are in
regular communication to coordinate
their efforts and Target social media
platforms with allies who work for these
companies we know this is a fact that
the government did this now Media
Matters yet to be seen but the
government did do this with vat who had
regular meetings with them and gave them
a back door and Facebook gave the
government a back door the US government
has gone Rogue in this regard I mean we
can say they've gone Rogue in terms of
War when was the last time the US
declared war they've gone Rogue in
basically every way you can imagine they
don't they don't they don't take care of
the Border they violate individuals
rights by spying on them we the I don't
believe that the NSA has stopped spying
even though there's they're supposed to
have stopped collecting metadata I don't
believe they are and the reason I don't
believe they are is because if they want
it they let Google and and all the the
companies these big tech companies they
let them collect the data and then they
just subpoena it so they don't their
hands are clean but if they want it you
they know that these big tech companies
are going to give it to them so they're
monitoring everything you do ring will
will monitor you with with cameras at
your house there's cameras all over
every major city the the number of
individual liberties that are
specifically
protected by the Constitution is equal
to the number of individual liberties
that the federal government violates on
a regular basis but I want to throw this
in there from the post-millennial Tim
cast the Benny show joined Babylon B in
pledging ex adbis to fight cancel
culture we're not the only one
a large group of people are doing this
we are putting our money where our mouth
is but let me just make sure everyone
understands when I say that timcast is
going to spend
$250,000 on a to support Elon and his
mission understand we're buying ads I'm
not just giving away free money the
other thing people should understand is
I am not saying that right now I will
write a check for $250,000 and hand it
to a for ads $250,000 adby unless specif
it could be over a year you know someone
could be talking about something like 10
grand or or 20 grand per month we're so
I I outlined this specifically in my
tweet saying the goal is for in q1 of
2024 to have spent $250,000 in ads in
the first three months and ideally
100,000 per month for three months so
that's what our Target is that's that
that's what we're talking about doing
many other people are joining in it's
not going to stem the bleed of the
massive advertisers pulling off the
platform but I must say this if we
believe that we are correct we must
support the organizations that we know
uh help us keep going you must buy
products from companies that share your
values if I'm going to buy ads in Time
Square screw that it's X from now on why
well Time Square ads were fun you know
we wanted we wanted to assert ourselves
in the mainstream space but if I
actually want conversions people who are
going to sign up for
timcast.net else if you're using Twitter
consider becoming a premium user of
Twitter for eight bucks a month consider
joining Benny Benny's show at whatever
membership levels he offering is
offering consider joining The Babylon B
consider joining
[Applause]
timcast.net on Twitter but but the
reality is or X look if he uses his
account to run an ad saying X is a great
you should use it it's still promoting
his account yeah exactly yeah yeah like
that's not really that's what I'm saying
like when I when I run if I run a cast
Brew Coffee ad I'm not you know there
there are these leftists who are like
haha these people are rushing to give
the richest man in the world money it's
like dude we sell coffee right if if I
buy an the leftists call you the richest
man in the world no Elon oh okay they're
saying we're rushing to give the richest
man in the world money if I'm selling
Cas fruit coffee and I spend 100 Grand
in ads and then sell 200 Grand worth of
coffee the that's how ads work yeah
that's the point anytime anytime the
leftists start talking about like money
they just you just know they don't have
any idea what they're talking about
matter also who donates money to Media
Matters of like if you could donate to
any charity right now George Soros but
I'm saying individual because they say
that they get their money like there's
no way like someone's like oh I'm just
going to make my annual $20 Media
Matters I bet there is like this says
that they don't disclose their donors
well yeah there's a couple people who
are just philanthropy news died j.org
says Media Matters receives a million
dollar from George Soros
2010 so I can't imagine
thenation do Charities not have to
disclose their donors CU that's
Insidious it's a 501c3 yeah I don't
think you're not is is it a C3 Oh I
thought it was I just look C3 yes C4 no
like they have to an individual itemized
every sing person yeah so pull up so
Google search this Ian uh Media Matters
990 990 990 those and and you should you
should be able to pull up easily because
they're public it's it's public record
if you want to be tax exempt then your
expenses have to be in the public record
now that doesn't mean you'll know
exactly where their money came from
it'll show you how much money they make
how much money they have it'll tell you
the salaries of their top uh staff and
employees and things like that the 990
will yep but they don't have to people
can donate I think what's happening I I
I I think it has to be public who who
donated I'm pretty sure 5 cuz uh uh 501
C4s you don't have to disclose and also
what else did the do other than like I
know they do they just are
like the whole thing is just truth and
media what what do youan like like what
is there their whole thing is making up
lies and yeah but that's what what I I
say what is their stated objective as a
charity just to police truth the right
or something I do think it's funny that
like when they run an article that just
quotes me I'm like okay thank you like I
said that but I'm like do they track
like all the dishonesty on like all like
corporate media no just on the right
yeah they orig or people on Twitter they
formed as a counterweight to the
conservative media Research Center and
it was like in 2004 and they were uh
known well they were known for their
criticism of uh and what it's quote war
on Fox News end quote so yeah they've
always it was basically it it is a the
anti it's a propaganda media Research
Center it's like if they don't have an
enemy to go after then they don't have a
reason to exist so they're like creating
enemies to they're just they they have a
the agenda that they have is just a
progressive agenda so it's like you know
if Catholics are getting together and
they're doing Catholic things you can
narrow down like the things that they're
going to be doing because they're doing
Catholic things right like stuff that
Catholics do things that pertain to the
religion if these if you're a a
progressive Think Tank then you can kind
of narrow down where they're going to be
spending the money and who they're going
to be trying to slander and trying to uh
harm their credibility and stuff because
they're Progressive so I mean they're
going to go after obviously you know Tim
cast and they're going to go after Dy
wire and they're gonna go after Ben
Shapiro and you know they're gonna go
after Tucker Carlson but anyone that
doesn't have the narrative that comes
for that the progressive you know
narrative in in in mind they're going to
go after him yeah there must be so
little work being done at this place
like they just must be chilling all day
trying to figure out what to do I mean I
know that they're they're they just they
have people that just scour the internet
and watch like conservative shows and
then make you know and say look this is
why this person's bad this is why this
person you shouldn't listen to him I
mean essentially they give out talking
points yeah you know it's like if you if
you watch the content that Media Matters
puts out you as a progressive know the
people you're supposed to hate you know
why you're supposed to hate them and you
have the surface level arguments against
the things that they're talking about
whether they be the daily stuff like
we're a topical show here they'll they
would have a topical show that would be
talking about whatever the most recent
thing that happened to that they that
they have to discredit or whether you're
talking about the more more uh Phil
philosophical stuff like okay why is it
that like you want to make sure that
trans people are represented in women's
sports or or trans women can play in
women's sports they'll have those kind
of talking points and essentially it
gives people the arguments that they can
take into into public spaces like
Twitter or or Schoolboard meetings or
whatever and they have the art you'll
know the argument that you're supposed
to make or that that's going to be the
most effective it's just an it's an
information distribution network is is
what it boils down to thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net